[mud squishing]
[groaning]
I've been watching out
so closely for predators
that I run straight
into something else life
threatening, quicksand.
Actually, this is a--
a little bit more
serious than I thought.
[sputters] What
makes this dangerous
is, if you can't get anything
to grab onto to get yourself out
of these situations,
with this hot sun
you could die of sunstroke.
[panting and groaning]
Fighting against it will
suck me deeper into the sand.
The way out is staying calm and
making only small movements.
It's like loosening up concrete.
[sighs] It's a very
strange feeling,
getting water to
basically lubricate in
between all the sand and mud.
[grunting with effort]
Once I work my legs
to the surface,
I can pull myself out by
grabbing onto the side
and kicking.
[groaning and panting]
Thankfully, one of my
cows didn't get in here.
A huge, heavy cow,
you're not going to be
able to get it out by yourself.
God!
[groans]
[bird chirping]
Exhausting.
Before we go any further, I
have to wash all this sand off.
When you've got all that
grit in your clothing,
it's grinding against your skin.
And you get all that chafing.
Out here, it could lead to
infection, which is just
going to magnify the problems.
Now my clothes are clean.
I can carry on.